i think that the internet is going to be
one of the major forces for reducing the
role of government
the one thing that's missing but that
will soon be developed
is a reliable e-cash a method whereby on
the internet you can transfer
funds from a to b without a
knowing b or b knowing a
what is a bitcoin what is bitcoin what
backs a bitcoin
you put some of your money real money
online
and it turns into bitcoin i don't even
know why we call them coins except that
they call it coins in a name i think
bitcoin is turned into a
massive multiplayer online game where
speculators are trying to out speculate
each other
is it a a means of exchange or an
asset class i see you taking my real
dollars
and then you give me virtual money in
return
thanksgiving dinner my grandmother asked
me what the heck is this bitcoin stuff
anyway
right and i said do you remember when
visa cards
first came out you were used to paying
with cash or with a check and then a
visa came out it was this
weird payment system that you didn't
understand and she said yeah i remember
that i said well bitcoin is just the
next evolution of another payment
system bitcoin by now
you've probably heard of it the wild
fluctuations in its price
has gained the attention of the
mainstream financial media
but bitcoin is much more than just your
average investment
beneath all the hype in hysteria lies
what could be
the most important technology of our
lifetimes
so what exactly is it to fully
appreciate the characteristics that make
bitcoin a potentially world-changing
technology
we first need to understand what money
is
currency started developing uh six to
nine
thousand years ago some sort of medium
of exchange
people used something of value societies
around the world though
started to select gold and silver as
their primary currency about three
thousand years ago and then in
about 680 bc they became money when they
were minted into coins of equal weights
governments
started creating representative
currencies where
you deposit your gold and silver or they
have gold and silver in the treasury and
they come out with notes
that are basically a claim check on the
gold so they're supposed to be as good
as gold because you can
always convert them into gold
throughout history precious metals were
chosen as money
not through government decree but
because of their unique features
gold is rare easily recognizable
portable
durable and divisible above all because
gold is difficult to find and labor
intensive to mine
refine and mint it has always been
perceived as a store of value
[Music]
at bretton woods new hampshire delegates
from 44
allied and associate countries arrived
for the opening of the united nations
monetary and financial conference
in modern history as world war ii was
coming to an end
in 1944 the allied nations met at the
small town
of breton woods new hampshire here they
drafted a new financial system
which would stabilize the world's
financial system once the war ended
with the united states poised to enter a
golden age of prosperity
the us dollar was chosen to be the
world's reserve currency
the bretton wood system was created
after the second world war at the
bretton woods conference in new
hampshire
and rather than using gold as the means
of exchange between
countries as was the case under the old
gold standard
the dollar was going to be used and the
dollar was chosen because back then it
was as good as gold
under this new system the countries of
the world would tie their currencies at
a fixed rate to the us dollar
and because most of the world's gold was
held in u.s vaults
the us dollar would be backed by gold at
a fixed price of 35 dollars per ounce
this created a system where the
currencies of the world were effectively
backed by
gold through the us dollar
i have directed secretary connelly to
suspend temporarily the convertibility
of the dollar
into gold or other reserve assets
the bretton woods system lasted for
about 25
years but in august of 1971 president
richard nixon
called for an emergency press conference
where he announced foreign countries
would no longer be able to convert their
us dollar holdings into gold
this surprise move would come to be
known as the nixon shock
with this one announcement president
nixon effectively created our current
monetary system
a system where no currency is backed by
gold or anything of value this is what
is known as a fiat currency
fiat currency is currency that's backed
by nothing
except government promises the word fiat
is a latin word
and it basically means currency that's
circulating by force
if people have confidence in that
currency and if there's enough
government force
that will enable the currency to
circulate for a period of time until
people lose confidence in their currency
money is a medium of exchange and the
way it has evolved is that it's
always something of intrinsic value
until the modern age
when the politicians say well we don't
need anything of intrinsic value anymore
all we need is political decree we can
say this is money this piece of paper is
money
now money has a new characteristic but
underneath it all
there's the same concept in place that
nobody
ever seems to challenge and that is that
governments have a right to declare
something of of no value to be money and
you must accept it
that's really the problem and it's still
the problem today
without anything tangible backing the
currencies we use today
governments around the world have been
able to issue unlimited amounts of new
currency
without restraint and with the advent of
the digital age
currencies around the world are now
digits in a global banking database
so what is bitcoin well simply put it's
a digital currency
much like the electronic currency we use
today
but it's also the payment network which
facilitates the transfer of this new
digital currency
from one person to another bitcoin is a
new internet protocol
that enables the transmission of value
over a communications channel
you can think of it like being able to
send a gold coin
as easily as you send an email you can
send any amount of money to anyone in
the world
any time can't be seized can't be
confiscated can't be frozen
uh very useful technology so bitcoin is
a
digital currency uh and it is a payment
system um
so it's a payment system in the same way
that uh bank networks are
or paypal those are those are all
payment systems
but it's also a currency so paypal and
banks use the dollar
as their currency the bitcoin payment
system uses
bitcoins as its currency so they both
have the same name
what is your opinion of disruptive
digital currencies such as bitcoin
if you're looking for the idea that that
a currency doesn't really have to be
something physical it can be something
that's virtual
that's the system we already have you
know
and if you want it to be i want a way to
make payments um
electronically that's you know credit
cards i mean so
exactly what it is that this thing is
supposed to be doing that we don't
already mostly do
bitcoin is different from other fiat
currencies in a couple ways
but not the way people think so most
people think it's different because it
is a
digital currency but fiat currencies are
also digital right so the dollar is a
digital currency the euro is a digital
currency
they're all just ones and zeros in the
banks of the world so
it's not that bitcoin is digital that
makes it unique it's unique
in that it cannot be created out of thin
air so
dollars euros yen these can all be
created out of thin air by
people who have permission to do so
which is generally a central bank
bitcoin
has no ability to create it out of thin
air so it is a scarce digital asset
unlike the banking system we currently
use where bureaucrats meet behind closed
doors and determine
and regulate the supply of new currency
mathematics and cryptography
are used to regulate the creation of new
bitcoins
the bitcoin network is decentralized
meaning that instead of transactions and
account balances being stored on a
central computer or database
bitcoin's ledger of accounts more
commonly known as the blockchain
is distributed across tens of thousands
of computers around the world
there's something called napster we all
remember napster we could download music
and movies from napster but after a
while it got so big and popular the
government came in
shut it down because of copyright
infringements no more napster right
so then somebody created something
called the bit
torrent network what's this this is a
software people run
on their computers that allows people to
file share
so if you run the software you can go to
things like pirate bay or views or bt
junkie
and you can download any music or any
movies you want and they can't stop it
because it's not a centralized
location well bitcoin is the currency
that runs on the bittorrent network
why was gold and silver considered money
for the last 4 000 years is because
it took work and effort to make that
nice beautiful coin they had to dig it
out of the ground and refine it and the
crucibles and the furnaces and stamp it
into a nice beautiful coin
and that took work so you didn't have to
trust anybody that they were going to
work for you
the work was already done well bitcoin
proof of work is the same thing right
you have to
hash away and solve all these math
problems you have to have the chips and
the electricity and yada yada yada
to create a bitcoin it would cost today
about 800 to make a bitcoin
i believe that bitcoin has multiple
levels of intrinsic value
the properties like being
unconfiscatable
properties like this censorship
resistant
value transfer that no one can stop you
from sending
more importantly what gives it intrinsic
value
is the productive capacity and the
brainpower
of some of the brightest developers in
the world
that have chosen to work on this open
source
protocol and this productive capacity of
some of the brightest
minds that are building it is what truly
gives it value
all bitcoin transactions are
cryptographically verified by thousands
of computers
on the bitcoin network these very
powerful computers
known as miners expend a massive amount
of energy
and processing power to verify the
integrity of each and every transaction
so the miners basically validate
transactions
all these transactions are flying around
and
they have not yet been formally vetted
by the network
if the miner believes the transactions
are valid it will
put them in the block and the block then
becomes part of the blockchain
and over time that becomes the record of
truth
and so that what that means is that if
you receive bitcoin and a few blocks
happen after you receive it
no one can ever take that money away
from you because the blocks have been
stuck into the blockchain they can't be
reversed
and you know that the money is is truly
yours
the decentralized nature of the bitcoin
network eliminates a single point of
failure
and makes it impossible to be hacked or
to be shut down
bitcoin transactions are transmitted
peer-to-peer
without the need for a third party
meaning that the user is in complete
control of their money
it's impossible to be shut down that's
the beautiful thing about it is that
there's no
place there is no bitcoin place you
can't shoot bitcoin it has no center of
gravity it has no headquarters you can't
shut it down the only way you could is
to shut off the internet
your average person has absolutely no
idea how their email works
but it works and that's all that really
matters and bitcoin is very similar to
that but as far as
what i would do to tell people or
describe to people uh who don't know
about bitcoin
uh what it is i would say it's a form of
money that you can just use on your
phone or your computer in today's
digital age where everyone's on the
internet
uh that is much faster to send than
most of the banks and it has for at
least since its inception in 2009 risen
in value
for new users the inner workings of
bitcoin can be quite complex and
daunting but what's important is how
this revolutionary technology changes
how money is transferred globally
right now every single payment that you
make to another person
goes through an intermediary either
paypal
or bank or visa or mastercard and more
importantly the governmental
jurisdiction
decides if you're allowed to make that
payment
that payment could be stopped halfway
through and then you have to try and get
your money back
with bitcoin no one can stop it the
moment you decide to send
another person digital value you can
just send it
and there's nobody in your way there's
no one that has to give you permission
to pay another person money and all they
need is an internet connection
this has the potential to displace the
need for banks
as a trust institution if you and i
exchange currency or you know
have commerce using bitcoin and it goes
on the ledger on the blockchain
we don't need a bank to confirm that
that is a valid transaction
one of the differences between bitcoin
and the banking system
is the it doesn't require a third party
to perform when you make a deposit into
a checking account or a savings account
you are actually loaning the bank your
currency
they now have title to it and they have
a liability on their books to pay you
back one day
but they get to do anything they want
with it and you have this
intermediary this third party
counterparty that has to perform
for you to be able to get your currency
back
cryptocurrencies invert the power
structure
uh it isn't a few people at the top
controlling a whole bunch the
of people at the bottom the power goes
to the individual
in the same way that the internet
flattened access
to information and allowed anyone in the
world with an internet connection to
learn basically anything they wanted to
know and to communicate with anyone else
on earth bitcoin does that with money so
now anyone on the planet no matter their
age or the
arbitrary geographic location in which
they were born
or the arbitrary rules of the people
that govern over them
that person can now engage economically
with anyone else in the world
directly that's profoundly powerful
you do not need a bank account to
interact with bitcoin you do not need a
bank account now to receive an
honest payment from someone else in the
world and know that the money is
is legitimate and good and can't be
rescinded so
money now can't be censored any two
people can send it between each other
through bitcoin
cryptocurrency bitcoin has once again
defied naysayers by spiking
above 18 000 at one point today bitcoin
hits a new high
we had this incredible run-up in the
fall going into the holidays
and then we've seen a pretty big
pullback this is a 30
loss in the week and a 50 loss of the
year
the past year have seen the price of
bitcoin rise and
fall in dramatic fashion getting the
attention of wall street and the
investment community
bitcoin is now seen by the public as a
speculative asset class that can be
traded
but the core fundamentals of this
important technology cannot be
overlooked
the use of bitcoin is particularly vital
in the developing world
where billions of people are without
basic banking services
people who see the price all the time
especially in advanced societies
they focus more on the price and they
think that bitcoin is an investment
solely and that it goes up and down like
a stock based on news and expectations
but the fact is
probably there's more people in these
kind of third economies they don't own a
lot but they own it and they own it
because they need it
not because they expect to get rich or
hope to get rich because they need to
protect themselves
against both destroyed fiat currencies
and
against capital controls so when people
think of it as an investment they have
to realize that
the reason that bitcoin's so exciting is
because it's a future money for the
world not because it's something that
could become
a great investment it just so happens to
be that both can be accomplished at the
same time
one of the great powers of whether it's
bitcoin or any other cryptocurrencies
if we can figure out how to scale the
technology
we can solve a lot of problems in the
financial system we can transact with
each other
globally at very low cost and very
efficiently
and there's tremendous market power in
that
has nothing to do with anyone in the
financial system
people want to be able to communicate
and transact with each other
simply and quickly and the hunger to do
that is enormous
today bitcoin is seen as a financial
asset but as the technology develops
the blockchain that powers bitcoin may
be used to verify transactions other
than the transfer of money
each bitcoin is divisible into 100
millionth of a bitcoin
called a satoshi these tiny fractions of
a bitcoin
can be programmed to represent assets
other than money
in this way the bitcoin blockchain can
be used to verify
transactions of all kinds of items
without the need for a central authority
the bitcoin blockchain is a tremendous
technological innovation that enables
distributed consensus people are able to
come to
agreement on what the state of
this ledger should be and what it is
and that enables people to have trust
without
trusting any other party or person or
institution
so anywhere we need to have trust where
we need to be able to verify
what is the true and correct state of
something
that has an application to be put on
the bitcoin blockchain for 6 000 years
i've recorded history we've always had
this problem when we want to engage in
consensual exchange
that is if we're strangers can i trust
you and what's happening with bitcoin
and the blockchain the technology that
powers bitcoin
is is now possible for us to have
trustworthy exchange
without those third parties the trust is
built in through the cryptography
that's guarantees the exchange of value
well that means that there's this
technology that is
it is as disruptive as the internet was
the publishing
but this is disruptive to these hundred
different institutions
that that really are the glue that pulls
society together you know everything
from as mundane as notary publics to
the land titling to coining money to
voting all kinds of these things are
going to be recreated in the blockchain
in a way that we will finally be able to
fully trust
but what that means is what we've seen
technology do to lots of private
industries is now going to start doing
the government function
the thing for me is understanding
the implications of what this is you can
take a hundred million bits of a bitcoin
each bit is called a satoshi right
and you can program that to be anything
of value it can represent
titles to automobiles or real estate or
diamonds or gold or
votes and elections anything of value
can now be digitized and tokenized put
up on the blockchain and
transacted can be sent across the
internet without having to go
through a trusted third party i think
the blockchain and bitcoin
it's going to change the world i think
it's going to change everything in terms
of
protecting people's identities allowing
people to
own property bitcoins for the 2 billion
people that don't have bank accounts the
5 billion people that can't prove they
exist they don't have title to real
estate and stuff that's
what bitcoin is going to change the most
for those people
is because you know they're going to
jump from the third world to the first
world
it's really going to revolutionize latin
america
africa southeast asia where people can
finally now own real estate we can have
a transparent election that can't be
hacked imagine
that's gonna change the world in and of
itself
tempers are beginning to flare these
people
have already been in queue for more than
three hours now carrying currency notes
the government suddenly backed on
tuesday night
because anyone can start using bitcoin
by simply installing an app on their
phone
bitcoin can be used by the developing
world to protect their wealth from
unstable currencies and government
control
we're seeing it behave as a crisis
currency in venezuela
in uh nigeria in zimbabwe
when these countries can't get a grasp
on their own monetary
policy people flood to bitcoin the fate
of the unbanked and underbanked
population
no longer lies in the hands of corrupt
governments
centrally planned economies and central
banks it really
there's a new option a plan b
personally i live in the united states
and a lot of people in the us
get bank accounts very easily have
credit cards debit cards and all of that
and they don't find that there are too
many frictions and pain points
but in a country like india there are
233 million individuals who are unbanked
who don't have access to a traditional
financial infrastructure and so they're
operating cash payment to cash payment
but bitcoin has become a game changer so
individuals and lessons can hold on to
it they can spend it
they can transfer it internationally
there are so many use cases
currently bitcoin transactions can
sometimes carry a significant fee
making it unsuitable for use for small
transactions
but bitcoin is programmable money
meaning that new layers and technologies
can be integrated into it in the near
future
one such development called the
lightning network will help reduce the
cost of bitcoin transactions
at the moment bitcoin is actually
suffering
from being too popular one of the
challenges that bitcoin has
is every transaction needs computational
power to process
so at the moment bitcoin can settle
about
four to seven transactions a second
and in the future each of those four to
seven transactions a second
can contain a million transactions
within it and that's what the second
layer and lightning
is trying to do it will just make it so
much more efficient
and so much cheaper for the average
person
the integration of the lightning network
into the bitcoin protocol
will scale bitcoin into a fast cheap and
efficient payment system
once implemented this will have enormous
implications for the developing
one of the stumbling blocks to doing
international business is the payment
system and to be honest if you're taking
credit cards from some countries
the those countries are so associated
with fraud
that your your rates on all credit cards
you take just become
astronomical and it becomes prohibitive
something like 33 of the credit card
transactions coming out of
africa are fraudulent so nobody wants to
take
business from africa it's just too risky
with bitcoin you know the funds are good
so as a merchant yeah
pay with bitcoin also anything you want
you know that's legal to africa
that has tremendous implications you
know to be able to get access to
these types of products and services so
seamlessly
and then they're able to start having
property rights and property rights
is really what's going to help lift them
up
out of poverty closer to home
in today's digital world governments
have started to phase out cash
replacing it with digital currency in
this environment where concerns over
personal privacy are very real
bitcoin provides monetary sovereignty
outside the control of government policy
when you have a situation where the
government is trying to control
they don't want people to have the means
of hiding anything
from them not just from a tax standpoint
they want to know what everyone's doing
in big brother fashion
so you know the way that i look at
bitcoin is it's the ultimate monetary
weapon
that the people have never had in
history
every government in the world wants to
go cashless
one of the reasons is that in a cashless
society
you are not able to exit the banking
system
when people panic they run to the atm
machines they run to the bank and they
withdraw money
the other thing is the governments are
starting to run out of money
and governments don't build anything
they just use
other people's money so they are
treating everyone as a tax evader
i believe the main reason why bitcoin is
so popular and important
is not because of its finite supply
and being gold it's because of
anti-money laundering laws preventing
people from doing what they want with
their money
one of the main functions of government
is to create currency
and bitcoin is successful
only because of its potential for
circumvention
uh lack of oversight so it seems to me
it ought to be outlawed
uh it doesn't serve any socially useful
function
as to whether or not bitcoin is is
illegal
or should be seen to be illegal cash has
been used for a whole heck of a lot more
illegal things that bitcoin has through
the years and still is today
uh cash is untraceable uh
it's easily transportable nobody knows
where that dollar has been and how it's
been moved from hand to hand to hand
so it's just a matter of making that
connection
that a cryptocurrency is really not a
new thing
it's just a different version and a
digital form of something that's existed
in our society and legal structures for
millennia
bitcoin is shifting the paradigm and
challenging the legacy financial system
recently jamie dimon chairman and ceo of
jpmorgan chase
america's largest bank was quoted
calling bitcoin a fraud
why is bitcoin a fraud here's the reason
governments
the first thing they do is form a
currency they like to control the
currency
they control it through a central bank
they also like to know who has it
where it is where it's going wait until
someone gets hurt
wait until it's used for illicit
purposes which is somewhat useful listed
purposes
they close it down you got people like
jamie dimon a serious guy calling it a
fraud
um you mean like there was hundreds of
billions of dollars in securities
that jamie dimon sold the public a
decade ago called more tobacco
securities
he's calling bitcoin a fraud is that
going to go to zero like his securities
that he sold the public
you know first first with respect to
asking a banker about whether they like
bitcoin or not that's kind of like
asking a king do you like democracy
it's just so thoroughly frustrating and
insulting
when people who know very little about
what we do
watch an up-and-coming technology and
have the audacity to call us all
criminals
you know we're not the criminals here
the whole damn reason this ecosystem
exists is because they're the criminals
and you know it doesn't really matter at
this point what he thinks the genie's
out of the bottle
somebody in this room or somebody at
this conference or somebody around the
world is going to solve the problem with
decentralized lending and value stable
currencies
and decentralized exchange and within
five to ten years
banks will become less and less relevant
just like landline telephones are
becoming less and less relevant
we're going to wake up one day we're
going to be in charge of our own money
and jamie dimon in retirement can watch
the world
as it is not the world as he would like
it to be
the bitcoin blockchain is built on
decentralized consensus
outside the control of a central party
however
with the hype in the rise of
cryptocurrencies such as bitcoin
both central banks and commercial banks
have started to develop their own
digital currencies
under the guise of what they call
blockchain technology
my big fear is that what is going to
happen
is blockchain technology will be adopted
by
uh governments and fiat national
currencies
will be uh run on blockchain
technologies and and
the entire sys the whole monetary system
globally will eventually become cashless
and at that point if it's centralized
and there's an entity that runs the
blockchain
they can lock you out of it if they
don't like what you're doing and they
can trace
everything that you do every transaction
everywhere you go
will be recorded and so uh you know if
we're not
careful this has the ability to enslave
us or free us
i think blockchain or any kind of open
ledger distributive database will have a
tremendous impact on our world
my fear is that and this is used to
centralize
digital technology gives a banker the
ability
to put a chip in you to tax you whenever
they want
to interface with a money system with
you physically
and to perfect the collateral so i love
the innovation and the question for all
of this
is how can we innovate and make the
financial system more efficient
and do it in a way at the same time
where we we distribute the power lines
in the political system
the blockchain is a technology which is
a good technology we actually use it it
will be useful a lot of different things
god bless
blockchain cryptocurrencies and digital
currencies
i think are also fine you know jp moore
moves six trillion of dollars around the
world every day
we don't do it in cash it's done
digitally if it can be done digitally
with the blockchain
so be it but it'll still be a dollar
crypto
currency a majority of the people
are using the word blockchain and they
don't
really care whether it has this
decentralized mining
the government is going to just have a
digital representation of the dollar
they can call it a blockchain but
there's not going to be mining
there's not going to be decentralization
it's going to be a centralized
coin whether they call it a blockchain
or not is irrelevant
the whole purpose of a blockchain is to
remove control from a central party
if you're a a central bank and you make
a blockchain for dollars
and then you have dollar coin if you
still have full control over the dollar
coin
you can create how much of it you want
you can control where it goes
there was no point in having a
blockchain at all you might as well just
have a centralized database
like a banking system
to really use blockchains in any
meaningful way it it means that there is
no person in charge and so a central
bank by definition is the one who is
supposed to be in charge of money
and thus they would never uh create a
blockchain or a cryptocurrency that they
couldn't control
so that's why they will likely be made
redundant because the market can choose
what kind of money it uses
and it now has a choice between a
digital currency that can be controlled
by
central parties and inflated without
limit or
a digital currency that cannot be
controlled by any central party and that
has a fixed amount
and can't be debased over time that's
going to be a very
obvious choice
bitcoin and the blockchain behind it are
incredibly powerful technologies
as the future unfolds these technologies
could be used to restructure the
financial system into one of fairness
and equality for all
a system outside the control of the
banking elite
we have millions of people now taking an
interest
in what is money the question of what is
money
what should it be and they're learning
especially a lot of young people
precious metals were once money then
came the era of paper money
could we now be entering a golden age of
decentralized digital money
only time will tell bitcoin is first and
foremost
about changing how the financial system
of the planet
operates uh however bitcoin is also a
financial asset
itself and it goes through these bubbles
and people have made many millions of
dollars
when they buy it low and then it goes up
in value but that's not really what
matters at all what matters is that it's
actually going to change the
entire ecosystem of the planet how all
humans interact with each other and
that's a very exciting thing to be part
of
[Music]
you